[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARTHCOCK:
Utilize Health
is a platform that
matches patients
with neurological
disabilities to the therapies
and the facilities that patients
need so patients can maximize
their potential for recovery.
Finding the first 100
patients was really easy,
because they all came to
us completely unexpectedly.
And so when we had them, we
thought, oh, maybe they'll
just be patient and wait.
Uh-uh.
They wanted help now.
They did not want to wait.
They wanted it
right this second.
And so Adam and I very
quickly devised a plan
since we didn't have the
technology up and running.
And we said, OK, how do we
best help these patients?
And that was through
matching them manually.
It took a lot more
work on our team.
It was a lot more work for us.
But, in the long run, it
was absolutely worth it,
and we learned so
much in the process.
ADAM HARTHCOCK: From
that, we actually changed
a little bit of how we
structured our revenue.
So now we have a premium
option for the patients, which
allows them to access
more of the services
that we can provide for them.
Kind of a concierge
service, if you will.
So it was really enlightening
to have that personalized
contact with them,
to learn their needs,
and actually, in
the long run, it
will benefit both the patients
and our business in general.